that's what we understood as sort of
true cinema is this notion of a
collective sitting in a dark you know
theater together experiencing a story
all at the same time some of those
videos where the audiences are just it
sounds like a rock concert and you go
wow this was really something special to
be part of
[Music]
captain america winter soldier
[Music]
the iron man movie made a huge
impression on joe and i when we saw so
we were big fans of what they were doing
at the time and we began a series of
meetings with them i guess it stretched
over two months we would
come back with a more and more specific
vision of what we would do with the next
captain america movie we felt like we
had a narrative excuse because cap had
gone away frozen in the ice for seven
years to look at him as a new character
as a different person when he came out
because because his entire context was
changed so the character himself has to
change and we began pitching a more
textured harder version of the character
we were more fans of what what where
that character had gone in the comics in
the 70s as opposed to the golden age
which the the first captain america
movie the first avenger is kind of a
love letter to that golden age so we
began pitching the
sort of uh 70s uh deconstructionist
version of what captain america is a
character who just wants to serve his
country how do you put that character in
a place where he has to basically do the
opposite of that
for as long as i can remember i just
wanted to do what was right
i guess i'm not quite sure what that is
anymore
when we started making movies in
cleveland you know
we were making them for basically no
budget it was just we were just driven
by our passion and our just will to try
to create something you know when you're
making it especially at that time before
the internet you know there was no there
was no when you were in a place like
that where you're a million miles away
from hollywood you're not really feeling
any connection to like where you can go
with movie making some of the same
locations where we had shot this no
budget movie if you remember the
sequence on the overpass in winter
soldier where the winter soldier attacks
the car carrying captain america and
black widow falcon
[Music]
[Applause]
that location was right above
a location where we had shot our very
first movie and that day when we were
shooting we had a thousand people on set
we had two crews running we had a major
freeway shutdown right in the center of
the city you know it was like the two
things couldn't have been more opposite
and that was very resonant i think for
us
captain america civil war
[Music]
what do we do cap
we fight
[Music]
this is gonna end well the way we looked
at those comics having been comic
collectors
you know was we're not interested in
telling an adaptation of the book that
book was created at a moment in time
there's a different moment in times the
thematics might not be the same it might
not have the same resonance it does it
may not work with the pre-existing story
that you know that we're working with
the marvel universe and so what's
valuable for us is to identify
which characters are critical in this
new mosaic that we're creating and what
elements are going to be critical to
that
and you know for us i think it was
you know this idea that and i think was
critical to civil war
was that the fight was going to be over
bucky and truth the fact that you know
cap in winter soldier sit at a monitor
and seen in fair proximity a photo of
bucky and a photo of tony's dead parents
and the retrofitted concept was that
bucky was actually responsible for that
it was the implication at the time
although we didn't know whether we
wanted to push it that far but once we
decided to make civil war we said let's
let's solidify that what if footage
existed
of bucky murdering tony's parents and
what if tony saw that footage and what
if tony saw that footage in front of cat
what would happen did you know
i didn't know it was him that was really
the essential um idea
that everything else in that movie was
driving towards is how do we how do we
put them on opposite sides and then how
do we create a crisis moment for the two
of them around this very personal
revelation that came out of a process of
us spending months and months in a room
together basically telling each other
stories pitching each other ideas
about where where this world can go and
where we can take these characters and
so it's a very it was a very exhaustive
process sort of exploring all the
possibilities
[Music]
[Music]
there's a lot of stuff that actually got
cut out of that airport sequence so you
know when you're working on a set piece
of that scale with that many characters
it's usually iterative there's usually a
process of trial and error where you'll
shoot stuff
watch it cut together didn't get it
let's go back or we have a better idea
let's go execute this better idea what's
nice about working with marvel is that
you have very deep resources at your
disposal so you can go back
and aunt and i are relentless and
exhaustive in our pursuit of telling the
best story possible when we're making a
movie like that we're probably shooting
12 13 hour days and editing four or five
hours at night and you know sleeping
very very little and so our process does
involve
you know revisiting the material in
chunks while we're shooting it and
seeing if we can improve upon it or to
see if a certain story element is
popping over another story element and
then we'll accentuate that and you know
we'll call marxist mcfeely and say come
sit in the outer room let's look at this
together and talk about
what else we could do to enhance the
storytelling so that's why something
like that takes 50 days
had we had the clear plan from the
beginning maybe it would have been you
know 25 days but that our process is
more organic than that and there's so
many elements that you're working with
there's previz coming in there's
storyboard artists there's ideas coming
from everywhere
and you know anthony are sort of
commandeering the ship and trying to
source out what we think are the most
interesting ideas and sometimes those
ideas have to be tied together with a
new narrative and i think one reason why
it may have taken so long and why we may
have had to leave some of it on the
cutting room floor is that
it was very important to us to approach
that sequence from every single
character's point of view you know we
didn't want to take anybody for granted
in that moment
everybody had the reason for being there
everyone had a crisis to deal with that
had an emotional component for them i
guess that's the signal way to go zigzag
we spent a lot of time just chasing down
the sequence from every single
character's point of view and filling it
out
avengers infinity war
[Music]
i don't feel so good
you're all right i don't i don't know
what's happening
i swear
[Music]
you talk a little bit about the juggling
act of working on both of those films
simultaneously well it's not good for
your health that's for sure it was
difficult i remember all of us at the
end said oh we'll never shoot two movies
like that back to back ever again
it's really difficult and challenging
but look at the process that joe was
describing where we like to be
we like to constantly be revising it
really did allow for a big interplay
between what we were doing in the two
movies and for us to be moving back and
forth creatively and i think that was a
huge
very unique uh creative sort of
opportunity uh that you don't have often
in storytelling i mean that the
star-lord thor stuff was really a
product of improvisation on set how do
we open this thing that's some sort of
uh
four-digit code maybe uh maybe a birth
date uh
what are you doing i'm taking your pod
no you're not
you will not be taking our pod today sir
uh
well are you making your voice deeper
no you are
you're imitating the god man
it's weird no i'm not and really that
was
you know riding a giant bucking bronco
for three years those two movies because
we're constantly trying to stay on top
of all the different story elements um
at all times well if we pull this thread
then in this movie over here we have to
pull that thread and it was a very
delicate calibration
really unique experience from a from a
storytelling standpoint from a
filmmaking standpoint and one that we
really cherished but azan said certainly
took a very physical toll
[Music]
arrested development
okay guys um
they are gonna keep dad in prison at
least until this gets all sorted out
also the attorney said that they're
gonna have to put a halt in the
company's expense account
interesting i would have expected that
after they're keeping down in jail we
were young independent filmmakers at the
time we had only made two independent
movies one was a micro budget and the
other was a very low budget that you
know did abysmally at the box office
welcome to calm when i think it made 300
000
prior to conway's failure at the box
office we had gotten a phone call to
work on a show called lucky at effects
and this was at the time where a lot of
indie filmmakers from the 1990s were
transitioning into television because
television is adapting a similar style
energy experimentation and storytelling
you know the advent of the sopranos and
hbo this is really becoming an
interesting place to work it was a high
broad comedy that was also very tragic
and very dark uh starting john corbett
as a as a gambler and won the world
series of poker
lost all the money his wife had
committed suicide or died of a drug
overdose and the end of the pilot um has
him giving his wife's ring back to
her parents and apologizing for her
death so
really really intense comedy and that
became an industry favorite that comedy
it didn't last long on the air i think
the tone was you know
too crazy ron howard was a big fan of it
and so we got a phone call from ron
saying listen i really like what you
guys did i think that reality tv is
going to kill
narrative television because
you know you can move so quickly with a
camera they can tell stories they don't
cost a lot to make and it's really
expensive to make single camera comedies
and you know we don't want to do a
sitcom so what do we do
can we go gorilla with it
and anthony i love the movie called man
bites dog that had one con you know a
few years earlier documentary team
following around a serial killer and
then the
documentary team actually gets pulled
into these murders with the with the
serial killer it's a very twisted comedy
it was shot extremely veritane we love
the style of it
we said look we think we can use this as
inspiration to make a show at a cheaper
budget that you know has 30 35 location
changes over the course of five six days
of shooting which was unheard of at the
time for television was very expensive
to do that dogma was also happening at
the time and um you know
part of the dogma filmmakers were you
know they would write a list of you know
demands of their cast there are no
trailers you do your own makeup well we
wrote something very similar to that and
gave it to the actors on arrested
development so we proceeded to execute
that pilot using digital cameras like a
reality show shot mockumentary style
yeah it was the first first uh prime
time scripted show shot on digital video
not shot on film that was all part of
the effort that joe and i were bringing
to it that gorilla energy that you know
ron howard was looking for in terms of
to shake things up with the idea that
reality tv was kind of eating the eating
the dial up in terms of how it was
expand how much it was expanding because
it was so cheap to make and so watchable
and so we developed this attitude of
well if you can't beat them join them
and i think part of the reason why it
works so well is that because the show
is completely absurdist but to apply a
very grounded verite realism to
documentary realism to it felt pretty
weird tobias now believing the boat
party to be pirate-themed no you look
like a pirate searching through his
wife's luggage for an outfit i should
say so look at the blouse sir
then mistaking a group of garishly
dressed men for pirates
tobias boarded a van full of homosexuals
soon he was unwittingly part of a
protest against the local yacht club
are you
oh my god i have the exact same class
we're doing one light setups we had
three cameras all running at the same
time we had operators filming each other
at moments remember we got a phone call
from the head of the studio at the time
on day two or three and she'd been
watching the dailies
and the phone call basically started
with what the [ __ ] are you two doing i'm
watching dailies and i'm watching
cameramen film each other and we're
trying to never cut together listen yeah
that was another thing that was said to
us is that the show would never come
together we said listen we're just
grabbing pieces we're grabbing moments
you know of course they're going to
shoot each other because we're trying to
move really quickly here we're cross
shooting it's rather than a pan through
operators uh pan through lights you know
we said but it's all part of the tone
and feel and look of the show and we did
cut it together uh and it did win an
emmy and we didn't thank that executive
at the enemies i think i don't think so
community
what is community college well you've
heard all kinds of things
you've heard it's loser college for
remedial teams 20-something dropouts
middle-aged divorcees
and old people keeping their minds
active as they circle the drain of
eternity
that's what you heard
however
i wish you luck
okay there's more to this speech there's
actually a middle card that is missing
can we all look around our immediate
areas having won the emmy for arrested
development we're in this position in
television where we could at night shows
when people would call us and say hey
will you do this and basically the show
would get picked up if we got involved
with the show we got 10 shows picked up
over 11 years we were working at real
you know volume and you know operating
as uh high-level producers and directors
on everything that we're working on you
know we got asked to come in and meet
with dan about a script we read it we
loved it we went and sat with him one of
the great stories
about what really convinced us
that harmon was the right guy to work
with is that we were sitting in a room
it was me and you and one of the other
producers on the show and dan and dan
was at the keyboard i don't think we've
ever told this story
but you know this is typically the way
aunt and i like to work is whether we're
writing or not writing or still in the
room
workshopping a script it's really
important to us that we get our
directorial thoughts out into the script
the script is king for us so we're doing
a process like that with dan harmon a
couple weeks before we shot the pilot
and one of the other producers was in
there dan and this other producer a
little bit like oil and water and uh the
producer had said something i think that
upset dan about the script and dan ended
up tearing the shirt off of his body
he's just going to two in the morning
and i remember looking at you going we
found our guy this guy is [ __ ]
passionate i mean there's probably a
hundred stories like that yeah postcards
somebody will write a book one day about
it
the janitor i'm yelling at me you're the
ones that got caught you're the one
who's yelling we're in big trouble we
have to do something oh i don't know
what to do my whole brain is crying
guys
guys
hey i have an idea
okay may sound a little weird but trust
me
so when we started work in television
the format became
predictive fairly quickly and you're
like well [ __ ] what are we going to do
with 24 of these stories right it's like
basically the same story every week but
we sat down with dan and
discussed like what happens to the show
from here what if we started applying
genre on a weekly basis to the show
to make it fresh because otherwise this
is just going to turn into a will they
won't they kind of you know annie jeff
story from here and what do we do with
that after one season i think it's
almost two was dan's frustration with
having to write that story he was like
this is too predictive and so we started
experimenting with genre which is great
for us because
we were pop culture junkies growing up
and this was a really interesting
playground it's not you know it was a
fun sandbox for us to play in action was
always a critical part of our diet when
we got the opportunity to the paintball
episodes
a good friend of mine justin lin came in
to do the first one who was working on
the fast and furious franchises he and i
had gone to film school together been in
the same class so we asked him to come
in and do the first of those ah
you suck
and then aunt and i did the second
series of those it was two-parter this
is paintball what was the spoof on
leonie which was a favorite filmmaker of
ryers growing up and the other was hoof
on star wars
[Music]
kevin who was a similar pop culture
junkie was feeding off of that energy
from community this different genre
a weak concept and then when he got to
those episodes obviously star wars being
so important to him i think he adored
the those two the back-to-back paintball
episodes and he reached out and asked us
if you know we had any interest in comic
books and we did and now we're here
avengers end game
[Music]
tony i don't know why
he made it for you
plus honestly i have to get out of the
garage before morgan takes it sledding
thank you tony
will you keep that a little quiet
didn't bring one for the whole team
we are getting
an old team
yeah
we're working on that right now there
was a lot of pressure but you know again
the thing that we could always default
to which helped us move through any
ideas of outside pressure was just
ourselves you know we were huge fans
ourselves we just kept focused on how do
we surprise ourselves how do we
challenge ourselves and how do we how do
we find the most satisfying version of
the story for ourselves because it's
just too complicated when you start to
think about the complexity of all the
different fans all the different
expectations there's so many directions
you can go in that storytelling infinite
infinite possibility we just really had
to use our own inner sort of meter to
sort of find our way through it really
was like diving off of like a
a 12-story building into a cup of water
it's not easy to please a
wide-ranging you know
highly opinionated diverse group of
people who all
want something different from the story
you're always going to piss somebody off
we learned very early on that you know
the fans were always going to be
contradictory look we poured our heart
and souls into those movies because we
we wanted to pass along the feelings
that we had watching large-scale movies
as children and theaters to other kids
no no give me that you have the little
one
the goal for us was was to make sure
that you know a new generation could
walk out of those theaters and and have
lifetime memories from being there
watching it with their family or their
friends and having a you know true
theatrical experience you know at two in
the morning in new jersey we fell in
love with movies as fans not as
filmmakers to be able to activate
that level of interest and excitement
and joy we sat in a few of those
theaters and you know brought tears to
our eyes that people were you know
waiting in line for hours going to see
it in the middle of the night seeing it
over and over and over again and it
doesn't matter where you come from who
we are
you know you're all having a similar
experience and sort of lets you forget
you know the sort of manufactured
divisiveness that's in the world today
the gray man
we had the pleasure of working with
chris evans uh for four movies with the
captain america character and it was an
amazing experience have so much respect
for how he was able to embody that
character what he was able to do with
that character the partnership that we
joe and i had with him in terms of uh
evolving that character and bringing
bringing that character on an amazing
journey that was a really rare and
special experience that we had with
chris and during that period you know we
naturally started thinking about other
things that we can do with him you know
that captain america character is so
specific it's a very difficult character
to play and chris does it masterfully
but he has an immense range as an actor
so i think we really wanted to find
something for him that allowed him to
use different colors uh and certainly
lloyd hansen his character in the gray
man is about as far as you could
possibly get from captain america he
must be lloyd what gave it away the
white pants the trash dash it's just
it leans lloyd
for as controlled
and understated
and selfless as captain america is
you know lloyd hansen is the biggest
loudest ego driven sociopath you can
come across so chris chris had a lot to
play with he had a he had a really
different process to go through in terms
of who that character could be but i
would say from our end we had the same
thrill collaborating with chris on that
character figuring out what we could do
with them and where we can take it
six is an odd name
yeah yeah just uh level oh seven was
taken
so six is character
uh gives part of himself
to help others to help the community
there's a character who
you know has been a victim of the
corrupt patriarchy his father was an
abuser a physical abuser a mental abuser
and the cia abused him the way that his
father did so he's someone who's never
known his own freedom but he still gives
of himself he still aspires to do the
right thing where lloyd is someone who's
entitled has been given everything and
he aspires to do the wrong thing and so
it's a very simple story about those two
characters and those two ideals there
are insane drone shots what were some of
the more difficult things that you
managed to pull off i mean certainly the
insane drone chats that you mentioned
are are you know one of the one of our
favorite things that we're able to do in
the movie you know joe and i love to
explore new technology and figure out
how we can sort of create
new feelings movements textures shots
effects through the use of new
technology and that drone
is known as a speed drone hasn't been
used
too much at this point
but it moves at insane speeds it almost
looks impossible to actually operate but
it's somehow works and uh we were able
to uh create a certain sense of energy
and movement that was very exciting to
us visually and emotionally that was
certainly one of one of the things that
we got really excited about you know
some techniques used on the vfx front
that are cutting edge there's a face
capture that we're using now that we can
replace
um actors photo reel and to stunt uh
players bodies if we're doing a
dangerous stunt using digital doubles
that are captured in a volume using the
real actor to do it obviously we can't
safely um have a an actor or a stunt
player get sucked out of a plane at 10
000 feet as the plane is exploding so
there are certain you know elements that
you know we wanted to pull out of our
imagination the most photo real way
possible
and there's a lot of new techniques out
there that allowed us to do that